die schwangere denise tut alles für
ihren älteren freund michael um an geld
zu kommen geht die 16 jährige sogar
betteln okay okay jetzt wird es jetzt
ist wirklich langsam die grenze erreicht
herzukommen sollte video vom kanal leute
wir haben uns heute wieder eingefunden
weil wir scheinbar alles ein bisschen
auf selbstbestrafung stehen keine
anspielung leute aber irgendwie die
ganze sache das ist für mich so aus ich
habe heute wieder ein neues video für
euch rausgesucht diesmal dreht sich
wieder um eine der hilf mir klassiker
folgt das heißt eine von denen die
meisten aufrufe von allen hilfe folge
never gemacht haben und ich muss
wirklich sagen allein der titel
definitiv schon sehr im herzen weh und
die folge gleich mit sicherheit noch
mehr das video heißt schwanger mit 16
mein freund 25 will dass ich betteln
gehe also wir sehen leider typisch
deutsche familie die frau ist 16 und
schwager der freund natürlich neun jahre
älter also eigentlich nicht fest wer
doppelt so alt wie seine freundin thema
geht für euch leute wenn ihr bock habt
151 euro amazon besteht zu gewinnen dann
seid immer unter den ersten zwanzig
leuten die meine videos kommentieren
ganz einfach indem wir zum beispiel die
notifications an macht auf dem handy
dann eine beachtung bekommt einfach
schnell kommentieren das war dann
informiere leute und jetzt haltet euch
fest verabschiedet euch von ein paar
tausend gehirnzellen und bedenkenlos
denise ist im vierten monat schwanger
von ihrem neun jahre älteren freund
mickey ihre eltern unterstützen denise
wo sie nur können okay leute direkt
erstes problem also ich muss wirklich
sagen no halo front an alle die die auf
feiern aber zwei sachen die ich nicht
zusammen sehen will
okay sind schwangerschaften und one
direction poster
ich glaube man kann sagen dass wayne
tendenziell eher bisschen jüngere fans
haben sich auch für ältere aber vor
allem jüngere und deswegen wollte ich
will dass das sollte nicht zusammen
passieren ihre eltern unterstützen
denise wo sie nur können ja scheinbar
nicht mehr so nicht schwanger für die
retter sie unterstützen wenn sie so
willi ist was deinen freunden
so jetzt wird es unangenehm wir müssen
mit ihr wahlweise
reden alle von euch diese wahrscheinlich
über 15 16 sind werden diesen tag mit
ihren eltern auch schon gehabt haben
aber auch ihre beste freundin leonie
freut sich auf das baby das sehr
authentisch
ich freue mich so auf das baby ich kann
es kaum erwarten bis es endlich im
arbeiten kann
deutschsein schnappte welche wird und
der beste vater der welt ich bin so froh
wenn wir endlich zusammenziehen
hast du diesen schon mal gedanken
gemacht wie du das finanzielle regeln
möchtest da ja wie viele
was bedeutet dieses wort überhaupt viele
teams kann die nicht viel die b2 die 16
jährige und der schule genau das will
ist die ganze sache ja und nicht sogar
zum talk never ever sollte das in einem
satz fallen für ein kind finanziell
sorgen ja also das geld für das kind vor
sie bezahlen und taschengeld pro mit 50
euro kann ich mir nicht mehr zimmer
mieten okay gilt aber ich denke die
kopfschmerzen davor weiterleitet und
diese herangehensweise okay also das
kind will ich auf jeden fall bekommen
muss man für kinder eigentlich bezahlen
oder der bezahlt und deine eltern ich
meine tiere noch kohle
vielleicht kannst du dir meine eltern
haben schon gesagt da kriege ich nichts
mehr was soll das g 16 50 euro
taschengeld im monat eltern sind so nein
wie gesagt sollte das kind nicht
bekommen wenn es jetzt trotz bekommst du
zahlen wird nicht dafür
also ja ich bekomme das kind auf jeden
fall ja das mit dem bezahlen
da kann man später macht werden also
kurzum riether leute meinen standpunkt
zu diesem thema ist glasklar kinder erst
wenn man wirklich mit sich selbst und
seinem leben gut klarkommt etabliert ist
sich etwas aufgebaut hat und dann
natürlich den 16
der radar mich ist der vater des kindes
vielleicht eher im muster irgendwie geld
ran kriegen oder nee also nicht ja auch
kein geld an tastatur steht ja gar nicht
also noch dass mein liebes kind also
hörst du dir selbst zu du bist 16 du
hast kein geld deine eltern zahlen nicht
dein freund hat kein geld für den fehler
vielleicht ist es nicht die beste
entscheidung dieses kind zu bekommen
aber trotzdem erst mal eine große liebe
zu sagen denn irgendwie schaffen uns zu
wollen ach darüber aber noch ganz gerät
bestimmt wo man vielleicht kurz davor
eingehen dass der freund einfach 25 ist
und sie 16 auch da sehr kritisch in den
allermeisten fällen ist das was ich
nicht positiv beurteilen würde ich bin
24 ok könnte ich mir vorstellen und
hinten nach 16 jährigen in kind zu
bekommen
wie das alles wird wenn ich mich
zusammen also darüber können wir später
reden was war das mitschnitt sie sagen
aber das wort zukunft die mit also mit
mediascape zukunft noch fünf monate was
hältst du davon wenn es mal shoppen
gehen nach dem essen und ja ein bisschen
rumlaufen und wir die sachen meister hat
gibt ja so viele sachen die von uns alle
anschauen
nein nein
also ich muss sagen leute real-tor real
ribery talk ich wäre es mal ganz ehrlich
mit euch diese person ist 16 jahre alt
und ich habe ihm schon gesagt mit 24p
nicht lege mir jetzt ferne als einfach
so einen kleinen bach seine kleine
wasserratten in die welt zu setzen also
nichts gegen den kindern was dort sagt
jetzt nochmals ohne aber das kann so
nicht sein
kriegst du nicht was hier habt was warum
gerade sie danach sollte schweißte
tricks ist seit ich wollte zeigen was
hier habe der scheiß momentan guckt man
bis aussieht hier ja vielleicht solltest
du erstmal was aufbauen mir aufräumen
ich brauch kohle am bestens fahrt euro
aufräumen 30 bio gate soweit ich geld
habe ich habe es genau ausgerechnet also
anhand das ganze müsste hier auch und
der fan forscher habe ich ausgerechnet
wenn ich jetzt 200 euro habe dann ist
dieser ganze müll die auf einmal
aufgeräumt
das passiert von selbst sobald ich zwei
euro habe also aufbaut muss ich nicht
also ich habe meine mama morgen für
babyausstattung 100 auch programme wie
kann ich ja schon mal gegen 100 euro
also wir sehen heute für das b was da
auf dem weg ist stehen alle zeichen auf
grün alle ampeln leuchten wirklich
giftgrünen es ist alles geregelt alles
perfekt die mutter hat kein geld der
vater ist pleite
die oma gibt nicht wahrscheinlich gerade
auf ihre eltern hat wahrscheinlich nicht
da muss man sich wirklich fragen wer hat
zugelassen dass dieses kind überhaupt
bekommen und 100 euro da komme ich nicht
so weit ich echt minimum 100 euro am
besten bis heute abend auch und da
kommen wir jetzt an dem punkt wo es
richtig herum wird denn jetzt wird
wahrscheinlich der nächste vorschlag
seit ich mein wissen jemand bei hilf mir
dass ihr freund sie sich jetzt auf sein
wort betteln zu gehen
okay ich bin mir vorher schon mal ob sie
das wirklich passiert
[Musik]
ich fasse mal zusammen feuchte damit wir
uns das ausmaß der schande vor augen
halten können er hat 25 hat eine
16-jährige freundin hat können wir
selbst in ihre freunde gerade 100 tagen
die fürs baby gedacht wagen abgeknöpft
sie geht aus dem raum raus und es zeigt
sich led fremd ja auch in beziehungen
gibt es so etwas wie ein machtverhältnis
manchmal sitzt einer von beiden am
längeren hebel und kann den anderen
regelrecht schikanieren und jetzt sollte
achtung jetzt kommt wirklich verrückte
idee könnte es daran liegen dass er 25
ist und sie 16
dass er neun jahre alt ist könnte ein
ausgeglichenes machtverhältnis einer
beziehung daran liegen das ist einfach
neun jahre altersunterschied in seinem
alter gibt also ich weiss nicht mehr ich
will euch nur zu keinem entschluss
zwingen aber ich werde es noch mal den
raum
ich kann mich da aber nicht mehr darüber
aufregen weil die leute es ist einfach
zu weit gegangen ist das kann man nicht
besser sind als manipuliert sie betrügt
sie klaut geld und beklagt sie jetzt
auch noch wenn sie schläft
okay was kommt als nächstes verkaufte
sie einfach so nach asien einfach
menschenhandels trader die schwangere
denise tut alles für ihren älteren
freund michael um an geld zu kommen geht
die 16 jährige sogar betteln okay okay
jetzt wird es jetzt ist wirklich langsam
die grenze erreicht wo ich tatsächlich
schwierigkeiten bekommen wir dieses
video anzuschauen
also jetzt steht sie auf einmal in der
fußgängerzone und hier ist er diese
wunderschöne mensch was hat er in der
beschreibung steht marcel und den ich
kannte mich wie gesagt die schwangere
denise tut alles für ihren älteren
freund mich okay ich habe die leute über
hilft mir von dem was sie geschaffen
haben so sehr verwirrt dass sie einfach
selbst die namen durcheinandergebracht
haben die asiatinnen sieht aus wie mein
recht dass ich gehe okay leute ich bitte
euch endlich zieht aus dieser folge eine
sache raus und zieht aus dieser folge
die sache raus dass ihr nur in beziehung
gehen sollte tvo ein ausgeglichenes
verhältnis besteht okay und das heißt in
der regel dass man keine riesigen
altersunterschiede hat das was wir von
hier doch die richtig einfach ich
vorgeschlagen dass wir hier oben könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren das ist
kostenlos und würde mich sehr freuen da
könnt ihr mich unterstützen ich bin echt
oder sowas von raus leute fragen uns gut